This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
Welcome to 6 Minute English. In this program we bring you an expressive topic and six items of vocabulary.
I'm Neil and I'm Tim. So we had an argument just before we started the show. We did Tim.
No hard feelings? None.
No hard feelings is something you say to somebody you have argued with to say you'd still like to be friends.
We often fall out over silly things like who's going to introduce the show or who's going to choose the quiz question.
But we understand each other. That's the important thing, isn't it?
To fall out with somebody by the way is another way of saying to argue or disagree with them.
Do you know that you wave your arms around a lot when you're arguing Tim?
No. I didn't know I did that. That isn't very British.
I know. Using gestures or movements you make with your hands or your head to express what you
are thinking or feeling is common in some countries but not in others.
Then there are some movements like shaking your head which mostly means no.
But in some countries can mean the opposite. That's right.
In which country does shaking your head mean yes Tim?
Is it a Greece, B Japan or C Bulgaria? No idea. I'll guess Greece?
I do know that in India people shake their heads to mean lots of different things.
There are plenty of gestures you need to be careful with when you're meeting and greeting people
from a culture that's different to your own to avoid offending people or making an awkward faux pas.
If you make a faux pas it means you say or do something embarrassing in a social situation.
For example, everyday use of the thumbs up signal might offend people from the Middle East.
And to offend means to make somebody angry or upset.
Now let's hear from business professor Aaron Mayer talking about how easy it is to misunderstand
why some people behave the way they do in everyday situations when we don't belong to the same culture.
A while ago I was in Dubai and one of my students, my Emirati students, was driving me home after
a session and the car stopped at a light and she rolled down her window and she started shouting
at someone outside of the window. This guy who was crossing the street with a big box of cloth
and he started shouting back and she opened up the door and they started gesticulating and shouting
at one another and I thought wow they're having a huge fight. I thought maybe he was going to hit
her and she got back in the car and I said well what were you fighting about? And she said oh no
we weren't fighting. He was giving me directions to your hotel and I thought that was a great
example of how someone from another culture may misperceiver misunderstand something as a fight
and in fact they were just being emotionally expressive.
Just gesticulating what does that mean? It means what I was doing earlier waving your arms around
to express what you're feeling. Aaron Mayer was worried because her student and the man on the street
was shouting and gesticulating at each other. She thought they were having a fight when in fact
they were just being emotionally expressive. And expressive means showing what you think or feel.
You were nodding an agreement there Tim which reminds me of our quiz question in which country does
shaking your head mean yes? Is it A Greece, B Japan or C Bulgaria? I said Greece. And that's the
wrong answer I'm afraid. The right answer is Bulgaria. In some southeastern European areas such
as Bulgaria and southern Albania shaking your head is used to indicate yes. In those regions nodding
in fact means no as well. I hope I remember that the next time I meet somebody from southeastern Europe.
Okay shall we look back at the words we learnt today? No hard feelings is something you say to
somebody you have argued with or beaten in a game or contest to say you'd still like to be friends.
For example I always get the quiz questions right unlike you Neil but no hard feelings okay?
That's not a very realistic example Tim but I'll let it go. Number two to fall out with somebody
means to argue or disagree with them. I fell out with my best friend at school. We didn't talk to
each other for a whole week. That must have been a serious disagreement Tim. What were you arguing about?
I can't remember. It was a long time ago. Number three a gesture is a movement you make with your
hands or head to express what you were thinking or feeling. She opened her arms wide in a gesture
of welcome or the verb I gestured to Neil that we only had one minute left to finish the show.
Is that true Tim? You're nodding your head but we should also quickly mention gesticulate which
means to make gestures with your hands or arms. A faux part is saying or doing something embarrassing
in a social situation. For example I committed a serious faux part at a party last night that I'm
too embarrassed to tell you about. Oh dear Tim I hope you didn't offend too many people.
A fend is our next word and it means to make somebody angry or upset. Well you've given us a
good example already Neil so let's move on to the final word expressive which means showing
what you think or feel. Tim has a very expressive face. Oh thanks. Another quick example.
I waved my hand expressively to signal to Neil that it was time to finish the show.
Taking my cue from Tim that's all for today but please remember to check out our Instagram
Twitter, Facebook and YouTube pages. Bye bye. Goodbye.
From the BBC.